bonsoir et merci d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation sur rt france c'est donc
deuxième attentat revendiqué par le
roulis non islamiques en quelques
semaines qu'est ce que cela traduit
selon vous
eh bien il faut savoir que l'ouganda et
très actif dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme islamiste en afrique donc
c'est aussi pour ça que qu'il est frappé
par l'état islamique c'est un peu ce
n'est pas la première fois il ya eu
connaissance qu'on vous dit ces derniers
temps on parlait par des attaques de
l'état islamique mais en 2010 d un déjà
laissé par les shebab un groupe
islamiste armé des de somalie avaient
déjà frappé et très lourdement le
demandera donc c'est une comédie reste
c'était ce sont des actions qui sont
menées contre les pays qui luttent
contre les groupes islamistes armés
alors les autorités ougandaises sont
attribués ces attaques hier à un groupe
local lié aux adf les forces
démocratiques alliées quelle est leur
champ d'action aujourd'hui et leurs
liens réels aussi avec des shs
partout en afrique moyen orient
il ya des groupes qui skie petits qui
sont madrid qui se greffe sur le sur
l'état islamique et ils peuvent mener un
combat pour retrouver cet état il
déteste la vie qui a été démantelée
militairement en entier en syrie en irak
et il sait comment dirais-je ray
articulé en afghanistan
en libye en afrique également donc entre
guillemets il avait il à des
des filiales ou des franchises qui qui
luttent pour pour avoir un état
islamique pour retrouver l'état
islamique qu'ils avaient en syrie en
irak donc
c'est tout à fait logique que l'état
islamique qu'on continue à recruter je
continue à intéresser à attirer d'autres
groupes qui ont le même projet il faut
mettre tout ça dans un projet global ces
groupes là sont
s'unissent pour frapper les
comment dirais-je des pays qui luttent
contre contre le terrorisme sable it
islamiste est qui et qui commettent des
attentats pourrait aussi imposer leur
vision de cet islam là et dans ce
contexte kampala est donc en état d'
alerte aujourd'hui dans ce contexte le
risque que vous semble important de
nouveaux attentats dans les prochains
jours les prochaines semaines mais en
fait le principe du terrorisme c'est de
frapper
ensuite ç'a créé la psychose est ce
qu'on voit kampala c'est tout à fait
normal ça créé la psychose sarah et
ensuite faire retomber la pression et
refrapper quelque temps après quand la
danse est concept attention va descendre
et qu'on est parce que toutes les
polices l'éléphant intervention les
services de renseignements de
l'occident d'occident général ne peut
pas être sur les dents 24/24 donc dès
qu'il ya des attentats
on remonte un peu les risques comme en
france avec un belgique irak comme en
angleterre aujourd'hui ils ont ils ont
remonté leur le risque d'attentât et
ensuite dans quelques semaines dans
quelques mois cela redescendre savard
frappé en ouganda en ouganda depuis
quelques depuis quelques mois depuis
quelques années c'est exactement ce qui
se passait il ya une sorte de dates de
harcèlement de des groupes islamistes
qui sont affiliées à l'état islamique
contre cet état là parce que le mandat
est très actif contre la ville contre
contre les groupes islamistes dans en
afrique est-ce qu'on paye a les moyens
de lutter efficacement contre le
terrorisme
la gestion c est ce que l'occident à les
contenir
il ya des américains qui sont alliés il
ya pas mal de pays occidentaux qui est
de l'afrique un jeu la france est
présente à également au sahel
les américains sont très présents en
afrique parce que l'afrique aujourd'hui
c'est quand même un terrain qui qui est
propice aux attentats par l'état
islamique qui voudraient déstabiliser
cette région d'afrique et installer un
état donc l'occident a tout intérêt à
aider ces états là mais l'ouganda s'est
impliqué très actif qui a des forces de
sécurité qui sont qui sont efficaces
mais le risque zéro n'existe pas on l'a
bien vu chez nous également l'emploi car
récemment ont réchappé a échappé à un
attentat
l'action d'un chauffeur de taxi mais
c'est un combat global il faut ce qu'il
faut pour ça non pas à pétain pays mais
de façon globale et l'occident ainsi que
les pays africains je dirais toute
l'afrique toute l'afrique du nord la
moitié nord de l'afrique est très
impacté par les par les terroristes
islamistes que ce soit l'état islamique
ne faut pas oublier al-qaïda et beaucoup
d'autres groupes islamistes il ya
également les shebab qui sont très actif
il y à il ya un an nigérien aussi donc
tous ces groupes là une vingtaine en
gros
sur la sur la planète sont capables de
frapper localement comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui en ouganda nationalement
internet et internationalement donc tout
ça c'est vraiment un combat qui a miné
depuis kakina qu'il ya eu de cesse de
s'aggraver d'empirer depuis le 11
septembre 2001 il y avait très peu de
groupes terroristes islamistes à
l'époque et aujourd'hui est là il y en a
une multitude c'est difficile de tous
les mails etc ok merci beaucoup de votre
décryptage pierre martinet un ancien
agent de la dgse directeur de wind corp
security la défense